on va retrouver côté
ukrainien Emmanuel Chaze à cramator ce
que bonjour Emmanuel stratégie
ukrainienne que c'est drone pour mettre
à mal la défense anti-aérienne russe
alors que sur le front côté ukrainien
Moscou intensifie c'est bombardements ça
a été le cas encore cette nuit
oui tout à fait et pas seulement sur le
front la ville de harkif dans le Nord
Est du pays était la cible de drone la
nuit dernière une personne a été blessée
je rappelle que dans la journée d'hier
on a compté les morts parmi les civils à
clivery dans la ville natale de volody
mirzelinski où on compte au moins six
personnes décédées 75 blessés dont 8
enfants dans la suite à la frappe d'un
missile russe un missili scander contre
un immeuble résidentiel à Helson se sont
quatre personnes qui sont mortes 17
personnes qui sont blessées dans une
autre frappe de missile alors l'Ukraine
répond à ses frappes avec des frappes de
plus en plus
osé sur le territoire russe on l'a vu
avec ces drones qui touchent la capitale
russe Moscou on a vu également des
frappes
ukrainiennes sur le pont de chaunas
c'est un pont qui relie la Crimée
occupée illégalement depuis 2014 à la
région
occuper la partie occupée de la région
de Helson dans le sud de l'Ukraine ce
pont il est impraticable et c'est très
significatif c'est frappe ukrainiennes
parce que déjà ça montre qu'il est que
l'armée ukrainienne allait moyen
désormais peut-être avec l'équipement
occidental de frapper ses positions
russes c'est également significative
parce que le pendant je vous parle par
exemple et bien c'est un c'est une route
d'approvisionnement pour l'armée russe
alors au moment où la contrefensive
ukrainienne est bien elle prend de
l'ampleur le fait que l'armée
ukrainienne puisse couper
l'approvisionnement des troupes russes
ça peut forcément jouer en faveur de
l'Ukraine lors de cette contre-offensive